oliver dowden does not say in this
resignation letter that he's encouraging
others or mounting a coup against the
prime minister or anything like that but
there are some pointed remarks in there
very briefly boris johnson just uh being
quoted as say he's in rwanda as we know
we'll be hearing from beth rigby our
political editor in the next hour he
says he will listen to voters but will
keep going after the tories suffered
that double by-election defeat and his
chairman also deciding that it's just
too much for him sorry
yes boris johnson uh saying he's going
to listen to voters the what i was being
told by downing street sources this
morning is that um there is no question
of him after flying back to the uk he's
doing important work at the commonwealth
heads of government summit in kigali and
he's due to be away for quite a few days
afterwards as well let's bring in um rob
and john should we they've been covering
these by-elections for us uh overnight
john to you um first of all you've
covered so many of these stories in the
past what's your um what's your mood
well that letter is explosive
for a number of reasons there's that
line where it says uh
we can't carry on as business as usual
he talks about recent events well
presumably he's talking about the
disastrous uh losses of councils like
westminster and wandsworth jules and the
tory's local government crown party gate
all the other potential scandals there
he talks about the activists in the
party being the backbone of the party
now as conservative party chairman
obviously oliver dowden has presumably
had an avalanche of either emails or
letters from
the local chairman and chair and
activists around the country saying look
you you've cost us the losses of uh
good counsellors uh it's a disaster
we're heading for defeat at the election
he's probably reflecting what the party
activists are telling him and just bear
in mind also uh oliver dowden's
background um you mentioned uh kay and
tamara the um the fact that he was one
of the the sort of the
the the first group of tories to get
behind boris johnson with robert genwick
and rishi sunat before then
he was a senior staffer at tory hq under
david cameron and other leaders he knows
the party machine inside out and one of
his friends has said to me today
and he he confirms that in the last
sentence of that letter he talks about
his loyalty to the party not to the
prime minister okay you and i can
remember cabinet ministers resigning and
they say you will continue to have my
support and loyalty from the back
benches prime minister well as none of
that loyalty to the party not to the
prime minister it sounds like a call to
other ministers uh to have the bottle or
another word beginning with b uh to um
to to rise up and and to also challenge
this mr uh johnson as for the results
here well i i kind of agree with lord
barwell that yes this was a seat the
tories only had a majority of less than
three and a half thousand a marginal
seat a red wall seat um
the it's the result in in
in tibetan which is more catastrophic it
was always predicted that the labour
party would win this seat back relief
for sir kiyostama after recent criticism
uh sakir we are expecting as party
leaders do to come and visit today
lovely thanks uh rob stand by for just a
second if you would please because we're
tomorrow we're hearing more um from the
prime minister in rwanda the prime
minister is in uh rwanda yes in kigali
he's spoken to reporters there and he
has said i've got to listen to what
people are saying in particular to the
difficulties people are facing over the
cost of living and he says
that
there is more we've got to recognize
there is more we can do and we certainly
will so the prime minister blaming these
defeats on the cost of living it's
absolutely true we've had some tough
by-election results this is the prime
minister who said
just this week that he didn't think
people of wakefield and tibetan would
vote against the conservatives but he
will keep going he's not going anywhere
is the message okay and also as part of
the uh statement um he goes on to uh
thank his uh former uh now former chair
of the party oliver dowden um
he says it's absolutely true you've had
some tough by-elections they've been i
think a reflection of a lot of things
but we've got to recognize voters are
going through
a tough time he thanks oliver dowden
after he resigned as tory party co-chair
rob
um
the liberal democrats pretty pleased
with themselves this morning
yeah this is a huge result for them i
think they were kind of quietly
confident um yesterday but to take um a
seat like this that's been really as
tori as long as anyone can remember in
2019 neil parish the mp that resigned
round here held this seat he won 25 000
more votes than the second place
candidate and that second place
candidate was labour lib dems have come
from third into first with a massive
swing to take this it's not quite as big
a swing as we saw in north shropshire
and i think some of the factors are
probably the same as north shropshire
there's an awful lot of tactical voting
that's gone on a lot of labour voters
that have lent their votes to the lib
dems in a sort of anti-prime minister
anti-boris johnson vote i think there's
a sense as well of exasperation a little
bit i think people think why not try
something new um at this by-election so
a sort of rebellious protest vote spirit
and then i think there is the issues
that boris johnson has been going
through connected to partygate as well
we've seen the local tory candidate that
stood um here having a bit of a tough
time on the campaign trail getting booed
at hustings at the count earlier she was
locked away in a room not facing any of
the cameras and then quickly spirited
away after the result
was announced but i think it is this
result that has really brought about
oliver dowden's resignation i think if
we were in a position where they had
hung on here the tories but lost
wakefield as was expected you may not
have seen um that letter get posted um
to the prime minister but because you
are in safe true blue territory round
here and whilst uh to a large extent
it's sort of meaningless to try and
transplant this into a general election
because so many factors are different
the fact that a safe seat like this can
fall will have many conservative mps
looking over their back